before we go I've got to talk about a
conservative who was not ever woefully
misguided a conservative who is a real
real role model for people today and
she's been in many ways written out of
history and now the left is trying to
rewrite her history when they put her
back into history that person is Phyllis
Schlafly
Phyllis Schlafly I had the great
privilege of attending a dinner with her
shortly before she died and so this was
toward the end of her life and she gave
a rousing lucid brilliant political
speech there as she always did Phyllis
Schlafly very very prominent in the
1970s fighting against the so-called
Equal Rights Amendment the Equal Rights
Amendment was this leftist nonsense that
tried to redefine sex and gender to say
that there is no difference whatsoever
between sex and what the equal right
there's actually a new push right now to
to ratify the Equal Rights Amendment
what it would do is in in the long run
at the extreme abolish things like
same-sex schools because men and women
wouldn't be treated perfectly equally it
would abolish same-sex restrooms which
is already happening people mocked
Phyllis Schlafly said she was lying when
she said that that would come to pass
it's already happening even without the
ER a said that women would be drafted
there's a big push again to do that
right now basically everything this
woman predicted about politics has come
true even though she did a great job
slowing it down by stopping the
Orwellian Equal Rights Amendment and so
one of those brilliant women that has
ever existed in American politics
there's a new show which I'm watching
right now it's generally a pretty good
show but at crucial moments they try to
rewrite the history I'll show you
exactly how they do it here's a clip
Phyllis Schlafly is debating some
feminists from the ACLU and this is a
real debate these events are you know
every scene in the show is based on real
events but then it gets interpreted
loosely here is how the TV show portrays
this debate going down I mean the courts
would decide as they did with a recent
Washington DC case where three children
were given to the father and the mother
had to pay child support it was they say
that was an advance for women but then
the larger issue is that the ER a
erodes the institution of marriage not a
static of course the case well I'd have
to look it up but the point you don't
know the name of the case well there's
so many cases we don't have time to cite
the case I can just name this one case
the point is if everything must be equal
in the logical extension of the ER a is
that we would have a gender-neutral
system I've scared the women of America
into believing something that is not
based in reality but when you argue an
actual point in the real world in a
court of law
you need to cite a case to support your
arguments of cite the case well I think
it was Foley breasted Langham or
Lancaster something like that you know
there is no such a case oh yes there is
but you see you just saw a cup I'm not a
lawyer no oh wow what a this Phyllis she
looks to her husband's you know the
answer she is so dumb and and deceptive
because she's making up these cases
right except here's the problem that
never happened that never ever happened
didn't happen in that debate that's a
real debate we can go back and watch the
tape you can find the tape the the
Phyllis Schlafly
Eagles actually the organization to
preserve her legacy just did a great
video on this comparing shot-by-shot
throughout much of this show all of the
ways that they completely lie about
history so I go over check that out on
the Phyllis Schlafly Eagles page this
moment did not happen ever
she Phyllis Schlafly never invented a
case in this debate she never invented a
case in any political debate and
actually what happened in real life
during the debate is that moment that
Phyllis got all flustered because the
feminists got her on the ropes in
reality it was the exact opposite it was
this feminist who Phyllis was debating
who was contrary to the TV show not
confident not particularly intelligent
not particularly good on camera it was
she who made an obviously false claim
and who got called out for it and who
couldn't answer it here's the reality
many lending institutions count a
woman's income only for half of what it
is if she is married and between the
ages of 20 and 44 and cannot show that
she has been sterilized okay that that
goes for banks that goes for department
stores are you saying that the enquires
women are sterilized Lieut
any place it does that there's any place
it does they do give me the name of one
Institute I'd like to I'd like to
continue there's a bank in Queens I'm
not going to name it oh you're not I've
never heard of one yeah but this
wouldn't be a plug if there is any
institution in this country because it
then becomes a major news event what we
want to know that case I can guarantee
you will be a front-page story on even
the date let me just let me just lay it
out I mean this is the choice of that
plate oh it's exactly the opposite it's
even worse they actually this woman did
even worse in the moment than they're
pretending that Phyllis Schlafly did
because she just made up this policy and
a made-up anxious so I'm not gonna say
the name why not you're fighting for
women's rights why don't you name them
that isn't that the whole point of your
movement well no I'm not I don't wanna
know I'm not gonna name my boyfriend he
lives in Canada no I don't think uh uh
no and I don't think so this is how they
do it this is what the left does this is
what Hollywood does cuz no one most
people don't remember Phyllis Schlafly
anyway because she's been written out of
the history books but now what people
are going to remember is this TV show
that's what they're going to remember or
they're gonna how are they gonna
remember JFK they're gonna remember
Oliver Stone's movie is anti historical
movie this is what the left does we
talked about on a couple episodes ago we
talked about how all news is fake now
all history is fake by that I mean some
of it's true but you really have to look
with a critical eye at all of these
things because it's about you okay it's
not about principle it's not about
telling the truth it's not about the
objective pursuit of what really
happened it's about tearing down a very
particular culture of a particular
country or a particular civilization and
they will do that by any means necessary
and we need to be on guard because that
is being done in clear ways through
political attacks that we see all the
time through policies that that
governors are forcing on us every day
and it's being done in subtle ways like
the rewriting of news and the rewriting
of history
[Music]
you